you can't be anything you want but you
can be
everything you are the real question to
ask yourself is
which one am i going to regret that i
did not follow through on which one's
going to hurt me in the long run which
one am i going to look back on and think
i wish i did that if you're planting
seeds in your garden
and you by mistake water the seeds but
you water a weed next to it
because you're still watering the seeds
are still going to grow and you spot the
wheat
so that process of watering needs to
continue
need motivation watch a top 10 with
believe nation
top 10.
hey it's evan carmichael and i make
these videos because you are probably
the most ambitious person in your circle
but you know you're capable of more and
you get that push by surrounding
yourself with the best so today let's
learn from one of the best
jay shetty and my take on his top 10
rules of success
enjoy okay let's kick it off with rule
number one protect your purpose
dharma is a fascinating concept i
absolutely love it
and the loose language terminology for
it is purpose
or calling or your mission
and vision in life like what are you
meant to do it's kind of like what
you're meant to do
and the thing about dharma is dharma
talks about how we think we have to
learn lots of stuff
when actually dharma is unlearning and
bringing
out what you already have so one of the
things i mentioned in the book is that
you can't be anything there's there's
two lies we've been told growing up the
first lie
is you're nothing you're stupid you're
worthless you're not gonna make it and
i'm sure many people listening and
watching have heard that from
teachers parents aunts uncles whoever it
is and then the other lie that we're
actually told and i don't think it's a
lie i think it's positive
but sometimes it's misconstrued is you
can be
anything right and and we all know
that's not true too
and it's unfair because sometimes people
get misled you're exactly right
and the dharma point of view is you
can't be anything you want
but you can be everything you are and
what i mean by that is
you have a genius a potential a power
inside of you
that you don't know yet why because
you're inexperienced it's not that
you're unqualified it's your
inexperience so people are saying
i'm stuck i don't know where my life's
going i don't know my purpose is
so you're perceiving yourself to be
unqualified or
under-qualified actually you're just
inexperienced
you just haven't done enough things to
let the magnet of your life
tell you what it's attracted to so for
me
that's what dharma's encouraging people
to do and this beautiful verse
from this vedic text a monk text called
the manusmithi
and it says that when you protect your
purpose
your purpose protects you and what i
love about that and you will appreciate
this because i know you're someone that
i feel is living this
a purpose is like a rare gem and you
have to protect it
people will tell you that gem is
worthless they'll tell you that that gem
is not going to make it they'll tell you
that that gem that jewel
has no value and that's why you have to
protect your own purpose
because the world is going to constantly
try and pull you away from it so dharma
is
a real it's not a belief system it's a
fact that you've got skills
genius potential is sitting inside of
you and you have not seen it yet
rule number two weigh the options which
one will you regret not doing so when
i'm making a big decision
i'll ask myself will i regret not doing
this so let's say it's moving country
let's say it's a job offer even if
there's fear of it not working out see
the question we usually ask ourselves is
what which one's not going to work out
what if it doesn't work out that's what
we usually ask ourselves
and make our decisions based on fear of
fear
right most of us make our decisions
based on the fear
of fear we think i'm scared of something
and i'm scared of it not working out so
i probably won't follow through with it
that saves you in the short term the
incredible thing is that
hurts in the long term right the real
question to ask yourself is
which one am i going to regret that i
did not follow through on which one's
going to hurt me in the long run which
one am i going to look back on and think
i wish i did that i wish i had tried
that
that's the one that you want to live for
because that's the one that
even if it doesn't work out even if it
doesn't go to plan
you're still going to be happy that you
tried you're still going to be happy
that you did it because remember
we regret more what we didn't do than
what we did do
what we did to dies after two weeks if
it's really about two months if it's at
worst two years
but the regrets of what we didn't do can
last a lot
longer connect with that ask yourself
that when you're making big decisions
ask yourself what will i regret that i
did
not do which option will hurt the most
in the long term
rule number three search for your dream
i talk about in the book how
daniel day lewis at some points he was
wearing the clothes for gangs of new
york in his normal life
to the point that he even got pneumonia
in his normal life because he's wearing
these
old raggedy clothes and he goes at one
point he almost went crazy
pretending to be someone that he wasn't
now when i heard that and i read that i
thought
wow isn't that all of us like you wear a
certain role to work you wear a certain
role at home you wear a certain
role with your friends and in playing
all those roles
you end up method acting and forgetting
who you are oh my goodness that is
beautiful and and for me
that's what i'm just seeing across and
in and of myself
and i see myself do that i become you
become who you think other people want
you to be
and so for me the first step in that is
writing down
everything you're chasing right now like
this is a great strategy and a tool and
if anyone's listening or watching
get a pen and paper if you're not take a
screenshot of this time code right now
and come back to this
because i want you to sit down and i
want you to write down everything you're
chasing right now
whatever it is make that list second
question
where did that idea come from did that
idea come from your mom your dad your
friend your brother did the idea come
from me or ed did the idea come from
i don't know some book that you read
like did the idea come from your heart
and your mind or was it born because it
was
influenced by your friend you just got
promoted
your friend you just got proposed to
your friend who just sold their company
for a hundred million dollars like is
that was that the reason because then
that may not be your dream
and then the third question you have to
ask yourself is is this my dream
or this is the question is your dream
really
your dream and when you go through that
exercise you want to keep the stuff
that's yours
and you want to distance yourself from
the stuff that's not rule number four
serve it's the story of two monks that
are washing their bowls
uh and while they're washing their bowls
they see a one of the monks sees a
scorpion
drowning and so he helps the scorpion
out of the water and puts it onto the
side and in that process he gets stung
by the scorpion
and the other monk says what are you
doing like you know this
stupid he said oh don't worry about it
don't worry about it the scorpion falls
in again to the water
the monk picks it up again gets stung in
the process and puts it
onto the side so the other monk's just
like okay now you're just being
ridiculous
like what are you doing he said why are
you saving the scorpion
when you know that it's nature is to
sting and the monk replies goes i know
that
the scorpion's nature is to sting but my
nature is to save
and so he understood how hardwired his
service mindset was that he was willing
to go through the pain to act in that
way so
what i'm trying to share with that story
is that we're all wired to serve
naturally as children as kids as people
as humans
but we've been educated for greed and
you see this there's countless viral
videos of kids who like
walk up to their television screen and
wipe the cartoon characters
uh tears off with their tissues or like
kids like running to help the person
next to them and we were all once that
person
but it's just the education that we get
and i'm not just talking about school
i'm just saying generally the the
education of becoming self-centered
and whether you look at it from a
scientific point of view the studies
that have been done when
people help people their depression goes
down their mental health goes up
when people help people they're able to
feel more joy and experience more
happiness in their lives like we are
happier when we serve and help people
and that i think has been so lost that
if someone
genuinely asks themselves because i
think everyone hearing that will say oh
yeah but i like to help people i try if
you really did an
audit of how much time you spent
every week genuinely helping someone who
was giving you no
help or was genuinely helping someone
who does nothing back for you
i'd find that we'd say a very very
little amount of time you know i
i can't remember who said this but you
know it's talked about like your success
i can't remember who said it but but
your success is
based on the depth of the problem you
solve
right and it's like if you look at any
success even if it's jeff bezos and
amazon goes i want to be jeff bezos
jeff has solved not that i know him but
jeff has
solved a issue that people had so it's
still
service and i think that's what we miss
that anyone who's winning even
financially
whether we agree with their business
model or not they are performing
some type of service to people and
because he's serving more people with an
issue that they have
he's able to make more money so even
from a totally financial perspective
service still wins everyone i have been
reading a bit from my friend's book evan
carmichael built to serve and i wanted
to share this with you
so according to a study by carnegie
mellon university
people with supportive spouses are more
likely to give themselves
the chance to succeed they studied 163
married couples
and found that people with supportive
spouses were more likely to take on
potentially rewarding challenges
those who accepted challenges
experienced more personal growth
happiness and psychological well-being
now i can truly say that i've
experienced that in my life when i first
met my wife i was just starting out i
had never released a video
i hadn't created any content and she was
such an
important part of feeling supported on
that journey so
whether you're in a relationship whether
you're dating whether you're married or
even if you're single
being supported by friends and a strong
community is important
uh build to serve by evan carmichael
great book
on how you can find your purpose and
also on reminding us
that we can all make a difference in the
world thanks evan rule number five
have the right perspective perspective
is a is a beautiful thing and when i see
the
level of pain that other people have
gone through at this time
and i'm experiencing the fact that
people have lost someone or something
or they've lost their job or they've
lost their livelihood or
some people have lost their homes and to
me that level of perspective
really allows me to look at my life in
perspective
and i'm not devaluing my loss
and i don't think anyone should devalue
or belittle their loss
but i do think that perspective is a
game changer
because all of a sudden you can look at
something with the significance that it
has i'll give an example like when you
stub your
toe or you lock your finger in a doorway
it feels like a ten on the scale of pain
and it's like the worst thing that could
have
ever happened to you yesterday i cut
myself on the side of my bed i have one
of these low
zen beds and it has really sharp corners
and i cut my leg and i've got this big
star across my shin
and it was bleeding and you know in the
moment that was the worst thing that
happened to me
and i'd say oh i felt a ton of pain but
actually if i think what
is a 10 of pain or what is a 100 of pain
it would be like
losing my family or you know something
terrible happening and when you look at
things with that perspective
all of a sudden cutting my leg feels
like a one
on that level and so i think that
perspective is really powerful
rule number six test new things take the
next month
take the next 30 days and every weekend
plan a new activity workshop seminar
course book podcast to listen to person
to shadow
person to experience with take a
saturday and sunday
and try it out you've got eight things
that you can now test
there are eight days eight weekends in a
month roughly
test something new on each of those go
and actually do something so this is no
more thinking no more reflecting
if you want to be a chef or you think
you want to be a chef go and do a
cooking class
see how natural it was for you see how
much fun you had doing the process
take eight different things and try them
out when you do both of those together
within 30 days you could figure out what
you genuinely are passionate about as a
starting point
that may change it may evolve but at
least you've got somewhere to start
and the biggest mistake is we're sitting
there doing a personality test trying to
figure out what our passion
is obviously you're not gonna know rule
number seven find
passion i want you to think back to a
moment where you felt you were in your
element where you thought you were in
flow
it may have been a challenging situation
but to you it felt somewhat effortless
you were performing an activity you were
doing some sort of
teamwork with another group now the
challenges that we usually think of when
someone asks you to think of your
passions
we immediately start thinking of hobbies
like art
music drama right science whatever it is
we start thinking of containers
because for a long long time in our
lives we've been trained to believe that
everything comes in boxes everything
comes in containers we think of careers
as containers
we think of careers as boxes but the
incredible thing about finding a passion
is that our passions are more like
environments
that we thrive in right our passions
or our natures as they're called in
ancient traditions
is actually environments a group of
elements coming together
that means someone can thrive it may
mean for you that you work better in
teams
it may mean for you that you work better
alone those are environments
environmental signals
that you can find if you're just
conscious and aware
of when you're in flow when you're
excited when you're making a difference
when you're making a change
rule number eight get rid of the three
c's
i really want you to think about how
envy is the art of counting another's
blessings not your own
start with compassion don't judge
yourself don't criticize yourself
don't compare yourself don't complain
get rid of the three c's comparing
complaining and criticizing get rid of
them out of your vocabulary
get rid of them out of your mind just
totally remove
right anytime you see yourself compare
complain or criticize
stop doing it notice it that's your mind
your mind wants to compare your mind
wants to complain your mind wants to
criticize
your intelligence wants a care he wants
to be compassionate
he wants to choose with confidence he
wants to be confident right
let's replace those feelings with that
let's re replace them for that rule
number nine
question your intention this is the time
to really question the intent behind
what you're chasing
to really question what you want and
your intent behind it because
so often our wrong intention for the
right thing
will lead you down the wrong path and
and i think we don't realize that when
we keep in my alignment that beautiful
statement you shared about
you know it's it's not the achievement
it's alignment alignment means
is my intention aligned with my action
and when i'm saying aligned i'm saying
is am i looking for the right thing in
the right way
uh and and sometimes even if you're
looking for the wrong thing but
in the right way you'll still get there
that's why intention is so powerful like
if you're planting seeds in your garden
and you buy mistake
water the seeds when you water a weed
next to it because you're still
watering the seeds are still going to
grow and you'll spot the wheat
so that process of watering needs to
continue and rule number 10 the last one
before a very special bonus clip
is have fun i was with someone that i
was coaching yesterday
and they said to me says jay be real
with me right you know everyone always
likes us like be real with me like don't
give me the monk answer you know
it's something my sister always tells me
don't go monk on me jay shelly like
uh you know i don't want to hear another
video my my my
my wife and my sister do that often to
me uh so someone asked me yesterday like
be real with me like what do you do when
you just wanna
you know let go so the honest answer is
i grew up in london
i'm a huge soccer fan or real football
and and uh yes
finally someone says it on our stage i i
never understood you americans it's not
uh i absolutely love football and my
favorite thing to do is play playstation
with my buddies
and play fifa i can do that for hours
and hours and hours and i'm pretty good
too
so if anyone wants to play me a game of
fifa i'm always up now i've got a
special bonus clip that i think you're
going to enjoy but before that it's time
for the question of the day i want to
know what was your single biggest
takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week when you watch a video and you get
motivated
the science says you have a 35 chance of
following through
that's not enough but when you write
down what time what place and how you're
going to actually take action on it
you jump to 91 chance of following
through and when you have public
accountability and you commit
to other people that you're going to do
it it jumps to 95
that you will follow through so i want
that for you believe nation
i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week
put it down in the comments below so i
can celebrate
you we're afraid of change my challenge
to you is that
not changing is something we should be
even more scared of
right people are scared of failure but
we should be more scared at succeeding
at things that don't really matter to us
that that's like something we should be
more scared of and that's an incredible
thought process i know a lot of startups
in silicon valley really harness this
distort process where they say that
actually we need to change
because not changing is more scary
because everything else around us is
constantly changing
if you want more top 10 videos they're
not on this channel anymore i have a
dedicated channel
just for it go check it out the link is
right there next to me
continue to believe and i'll see you
there